for almost a century we've been
captivated and sometimes terrified by
the big questions of artificial
intelligence questions like will
computers ever become truly intelligent
what will happen if machines develop a
conscience
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives six experts
in the fields of robotics sci-fi and
philosophy discuss breakthroughs in the
development of ai that are both good and
a bit worrisome we begin now with a
major milestone in the field of
artificial intelligence the development
of the touring test enjoy
[Music]
in 1950 turing published his definitive
philosophical piece on the question of
mines and machines and information
can a machine think that question he
says is too meaningless to merit
attention
there perhaps we see the influence of
wittgenstein wittgenstein said that
asking whether a machine can think is
like asking whether the number three has
a color
turing rejects can a machine think as
meaningless
but proposes replacing that question
with one that isn't meaningless
it's called the turing test
could you build a machine that under
specified conditions was
indistinguishable from a person
if your communication was limited to
written questions and responses by email
would you be able to tell whether it was
a person or a machine on the other end
turing's article on the turing test
where a major instigation for the field
of artificial intelligence a term that
wasn't invented until after turing's
death in 1954.
in 1956 a group of collaborators put
together a dartmouth summer research
project on
they didn't know quite what to call it
but eventually settled on the dartmouth
summer research project on artificial
intelligence
the theme was clearly along turing's
lines of inquiry the conference was
explicitly based on the conjecture
that every aspect of learning or any
other feature of intelligence can in
principle be so precisely described that
a machine can be made to simulate it
an attempt will be made to find
how to make machines use language form
abstractions and concepts solve kinds of
problems now reserved for humans and
improve themselves
there are actually two branches of
artificial intelligence that came out of
the conference one involves straight
programming on the model of the turing
machine
the other involved the first
explorations in neural nets
another line of thought that turing had
anticipated
neural networks have variables that can
be set to any possible numeric value
allowing fine scale control over their
behavior
in practice this fine scale control
often works like the sliders on a mixing
board that sound engineers use
it's not just on off or the counting
numbers 1 2 3 up to 10
it's also everything in between
so thanks to this very fine scale
control neural networks give us an
approach to machine learning that can
build much more complicated systems of
rules using very low level inputs such
as sound or images
these more complicated systems of rules
would be hard for humans to derive
explicitly or even fully understand
humans don't think of pictures in terms
of pixels or sounds in terms of sound
waves
and yet focusing on these low-level
features is what makes it possible for
machines to solve perceptual problems on
our behalf
neural networks allow machines to do the
hard work of identifying higher level
patterns from lower level inputs
for example
words from acoustic signals
people from images of their faces
letters from handwritten stroke
information and breeds of dogs from
photographs
deep learning which has exploded in
impact and popularity since 2015 is just
an approach to building and training
neural networks with many layers
the first generally accepted passing of
the turing test was elisa a computer
program written in 1965 at mit by the
german-born computer scientist joseph
weizenbaum a jewish scientist who fled
the rise of nazism
eliza was the first chatterbot or bot as
we now call them it was a complex
program that allows for conversational
exchanges in natural language as it's
generally spoken
eliza was set up to simulate the
conversation between a patient and a
psychiatrist
using recognizable linguistic patterns
and pre-programmed relations between
terms eliza was able to carry on
conversations that really did seem
exactly like those one would have with a
therapist
request for clarification why do you
think you're worried about the future or
questions that would naturally follow
from a claim were asked you say you've
been away from home a lot could you tell
me about your family life many of those
who interacted with eliza were convinced
that it could not be a computer program
indeed some still thought that eliza was
human even after being shown what it was
and having received a detailed
explanation as to how it works
however we have yet to achieve true
artificial intelligence why is that
primarily because no one really knows
what intelligence means
i'm going to call this the problem of
self-awareness
the problem is that no two researchers
in ai seem to agree on what
self-awareness means
to give you an idea of the scope of this
problem a 2009 paper on artificial
intelligence lists no less than 28
distinct models of consciousness
these models define the approaches that
researchers use to try to achieve
artificial intelligence some approaches
like using neural networks for problem
solving are bottom up
they start from a level that is similar
to how neurons in the brain interact
and try to build useful systems from
that
some are top top-down they attempt to
model large-scale systems in the brain
like recognizing patterns using more
general strategies and ignoring the
bottom levels
some approaches have different
subsystems which interact together and
use feedback between them
some researchers use the human brain as
a model and some ignore it
some researchers believe that building a
true thinking machine is impossible
others that will be achieved in a few
decades
maybe less
i think that creating a true thinking
machine is possible
because nature has already done it in
the form of a human brain
how we will create it either by growing
it in a vat
or programming it in silicon or some
other method i don't know
but if we accept that the laws of nature
allow natural intelligence recreating it
artificially is possible
by the 1960s asimov was nearly as well
known for his popular science books as
for his science fiction writing
so it's not surprising that asimov would
want to explore the possible benefits of
technology and together with the
legendary science fiction editor john w
campbell jr
he tried to alleviate fears of robot
uprisings by coming up with his three
laws of robotics
which has proved to be one of the most
durable enduring ideas in science
fiction a version of them even does show
up in that irobot movie
one of the few elements of asimov's
story is to survive in that film
they're essentially programming rules
the three laws are
one a robot may not injure a human being
or through inaction allow a human human
being to come to harm
two a robot must obey the orders given
it by human beings except for such
orders would conflict with the first law
and three
a robot must protect its own existence
as long as such protection does not
conflict with the first or second law
this is really kind of a clever logical
trap with each law overruling the one
below it
the idea was to set up a system of
simple rules that would prevent for
example somebody using a robot to commit
murder or to go on these destructive
rampages such as we saw in those earlier
pulp stories
neural networks reinforcement learning
and other methods of creating artificial
intelligence can make it difficult to
figure out why a machine made a
particular decision
because their choices emerge from the
learning algorithms on which they're
trained it's hard to pinpoint the cause
of a decision
but that's true too of the vast majority
of the decisions that we make including
those of judges mortgage brokers and
doctors
the difference is that we can force
makers of ai to find out the cause of
the decision
but we can't force it out of other
humans
so what are the implications of
programming an ai that can explain its
decisions
in order for the ai to explain a
decision
it needs to know itself
in a sense
it needs to be made conscious of its own
thinking or have some kind of
metacognition
when classifying a face as male or
female the machine would have to explain
how it came to make that choice was it a
particular feature a relationship
between features a probabilistic map of
features and in this we're bound to gain
a deeper understanding of our own
metacognition
and ultimately maybe even our own
consciousness
perhaps the best use of ai and the least
scary is as a partner
since computers are much better than we
are at brute force calculations and
search we can outsource those tasks and
benefit greatly
say you want to build a new car for
instance
there are many different parts and
options to consider each with its own
pros and cons
by building a digital twin or a digital
replica of your design you can
simultaneously test out many different
versions using digital simulations
before ai engineers had to do much of
this work themselves testing and
retesting prototypes
but now they can outsource it to
machines and get answers much more
quickly
that means that they can spend the extra
time on the more creative tasks
innovating and connecting which is what
we humans do better so far than our
computer counterparts
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here